hi all
my name is tigran cetera
today i'm going to present
grover's quantum search for machine
learning i've been studying quantum
computing for the past year
sorbonne university and
recently i i've gained some insights on
applications of quantum computing for
machine learning
and today i'm going to present them
particularly i'm
going to start with a very brief history
of quantum computing i'm going to
introduce the mathematical concepts of
quantum computing then i'm going to
present grover's algorithm one of the
main players in the field
then i'm going to proceed with the with
the applications
to the machine learning field
specifically
and i'm going to talk uh a bit about
quantum supremacy
uh advantages challenges associated with
quantum computing uh
so but uh first of all i i'd like to ask
you a question i wonder if there's
anyone in the audience who's familiar
with quantum computing already
uh it's a
it's a field uh of a subfield of
computer science which utilizes concepts
of quantum mechanics
some very
essential principles like superposition
and entanglement
to achieve a better efficiency in
various
computations so without further ado
let's uh
let's let's begin
uh a very brief history first uh first
quantum computational model uh that is
quantum mechanical model of
uh quantum turing machine was introduced
in 1980.
after that in 1986 a very early
annotation of quantum circuit was
invented
in 1994 and 96 correspondingly schwarz
and grover's algorithms were
discovered which were an important
important milestones in the in the field
uh the first two cubic quantum computer
uh the working version was invented in
98
and
after that it's been one milestone after
another more importantly
uh the first quantum computation in
feasible and classical computers was
made in 2019
uh
however it's been questioned
and it hasn't been rigorously proven
only very recently chinese researchers
managed to indeed rigorously
make a quantum computation in four hours
which would take uh
many many thousands of years on
uh classical computers
and we have the three dots here to
signify that the field is still in very
active development right now and
new big things are happening pretty much
every every other month
so
i want to introduce the mathematical
model of quantum computing
qubits and logic gates and then proceed
with the quantum circuit notations
uh
here we have examples of what we call
qubits physically those are
quantum anything that have two basic
states
we call them zero state and one state
and unlike classical bits qubits are
represented as factors which allows us
to
to make a continuum of uh of of of
vectors by
uh making linear combinations of those
uh in a very general sense qubit is
represented as a linear combination of
the zero vector and and the one vector
uh where uh
with with corresponding alpha and beta
coefficients as you can see
here
those are complex numbers uh and this
allows for a lot of flexibility
they are called probability amplitudes
and they correspond to
uh to a certain measurement
probabilities what is the measurement
mathematically it's a projection
on a subspace of uh the span by zero and
uh the zero and the one cubit
and uh
after after a measurement we stay we say
that a superposed state as we can see
here
it collapses to either a zero or one
state
uh we call uh
psi uh
quantum superposition of the zero and of
the one state
which uh and the the basic principle of
superposition is that
the
the qubit the quantum state is in uh
several states pretty much
simultaneously
which allows for a phenomenon called
quantum parallelism thus for example
applying
functions or making computations on the
single qubit here we we can therefore
apply
this dysfunctions and make these
computations for the
for for both of them uh the zero and one
qubit
uh naturally when measuring a qubit we
understand that it
collapses to state so it becomes a zero
state or one state
and uh
we have two possibilities thus uh the
the sum of the probabilities
of collapsing to either state
uh sums up to 1 which we call the
normalization condition
as alpha and beta are complex numbers a
qubit is a complex vector
and
and we can
see an example representation of the
qubit on the
on the right uh we call this the bloch
sphere of a qubit
uh we can see the basis states zero and
the one state on the poles
opposing poles and uh
all the
corresponding values in between formed
by this uh this linear combination are a
fall on this sphere
uh thus we have an infinite continuum of
of possible states represented just by
two two basic two basis states zero and
one and corresponding coefficients alpha
and beta
uh
like uh
an alternative to to classical logic
gates in quantum computing or
are
quantum logic gates
we can see examples here for example the
x-gate or the not gate flips a zero
cubit to one qubit and vice versa
it corresponds to rotation around the x
axis on the on the block sphere
uh likewise y and z uh
gates uh correspond to rotations
around y and z axis correspondingly uh
at the bottom row we have uh four
examples of quantum logic gates which
is uh usually considered as the
universal set of quantum gates which
allow for for universal computation
uh
it is it is not not it is not a unique
uh set but
it is it is the most commonly used one
uh in order to apply a gate on a on a
qubit as we can as we will see in a bit
on the quantum circuit
we have to mathematically it will
correspond to multiplying the
corresponding matrix on the left
with the the with the qubit
of special interest here is the harder
mark gig
which allows for
creating a uniform superposition of
states
i will i will discuss this term in a bit
just just remember this for now
uh excuse me
um here we here we see an example of
what we call a quantum circuit it is not
very similar to the classic classical
circuit but it definitely has some
similarities on the left we have qubits
quantum states
in the middle we have the operation flow
applying certain operations and logic
gates
and in the end we have
we have the output states
uh the thing that we we actually trying
to achieve
here we can see examples of gates for
example the haramard gate
shown here it acts on one qubit and
it gives a corresponding output
also we can see these interesting
notations which we call
measurements
they correspond to
a measurement of a qubit in a in a
certain
uh basis of of of two-dimensional vector
space uh why why do we keep measurements
for the very end
uh why do we need measurements in the
first case uh we need measurements to
obtain classical values which we'll be
able to interpret
for further computations
but
in general we keep the measurements for
the very end because as i mentioned
before
measurements cause a superposed
states to collapse
and uh
as we shall see in a bit it's very
important for us to keep the
superposition of a state because uh
that's the primary thing that
allows for more efficient computations
on quantum computers
uh
i guess that's it for the mathematical
model of quantum computing a very basic
uh introduction
uh and i'd like to discuss shortly what
makes quantum computing so powerful as i
already mentioned a superposition of
several states allows us to apply
functions
uh which we call unitaries
on several on the on the superposition
superposition state and thus
allowing us to play it on several
different
quantum quantum states at the same time
now we also have the principle of
entanglement
uh
which
which allows for more efficient
communication we call this this field of
study quantum communication
and
uh these these two principles together
pretty much form the basis for quantum
computation and allow us for for more
efficient computing
uh i'd like to discuss the the hero of
the day grover's algorithm
i will i will shortly uh talk about it
the the main principles i'll discuss the
main steps of the algorithm
a process called amplitude amplification
and then
the variant i'll show a corresponding
quantum circuit for it
so what is grover's algorithm it's an
algorithm for uh unstructured search
uh
thus does a search on unstructured data
for example there are efficient
search algorithms on structured data for
example index databases and such
but in the unstructured data field
grover's algorithm outperforms any
classical alternative uh in a in a
quadratic manner so we have all square
root of and time complexity for grover's
algorithm whereas the best classical
alternatives performed in all of n
and it's also been proven that is
asymptotically optimal
and uh there are no existing uh better
uh quantum or even moreover classical
algorithms for unstructured research uh
it's important to mention that we're
searching among quantum states
and uh in order to
be able to use this data classically
we'll have to come up to include
classical bits into quantum
quantum bits and vice versa
which is which is still in pretty active
research that the efficient ways of
doing so because oftentimes encoding
states may take more time than the
computation itself
uh so uh here uh here are the main steps
of grover's algorithm the
initializations tab
here we create a uniform superposition
of quantum states
uh
which which corresponds to
uh to
superposition of states with equal
probability amplitudes uh the ones i've
discussed before for example alpha and
beta in this case they become all all of
them are equal all alphas and betas are
equal and all of them are equal to one
over n so the probability of measuring
every state when measuring the
superposed state is
is equal to one over n
we have uh the the we have we
initialized the
uh uniform superposition state from a
zero state uh the zero state that we've
seen before by applying uh hardware
gates
how this is done more specifically is a
bit complicated subject so i won't go
deep into it just uh for now just know
that
a superposition state uh has an equal
probability of uh for superposition
state we have an equal probability of
measuring
every state in the superposition uh
which which allows uh which allows us
for uh better computations
uh grover's uh iteration or amplitude
amplification as uh
is the second main step of grover
algorithm
we we mark the state that we want to uh
to measure
by applying a certain gate a certain
unitary uh we mark it by
uh changing the the design of its
amplitude to negative we will see some
visuals in the next slide to make it
more clear
after that we apply a gate called the
diffuser gate which pretty much
uh takes the the
state that we marked and empty amplifies
its amplitude uh in a way that uh
we we will end up we will have a higher
probability of measuring that state
which is the state exactly the state
that we're looking for and the the final
step would be the measurement
of
of the of the corresponding uh
superposed state that we that we already
modified somehow in order to
obtain with very high probability
the
the the the quantum state that we were
looking for
here here we have some visuals for
amplitude amplification
as i mentioned before quantum states can
be represented as vectors in
two-dimensional space
here we have a quantum superposition
state s from the previous slide
which also contains the state that we're
looking for
so we will start by creating this
superposition
and we will we will look for this state
specifically in this superposition using
grover's algorithm
since this state also contains the the
one that we're looking for they're not
orthogonal to each other and it's
convenient to create another axis in
this coordinate system which will be
orthogonal to the state that we're
looking for
it will uh it will be s prime as prime
here
uh is achieved by removing w from s
and our primary goal is to rotate this
vector towards w and away from s prime
so that when measuring in the end we'll
achieve with our probability the state w
uh
here here we have uh
the the corresponding amplitude picture
as we can see all of the all of the
states in the superposition have equal
equal entities of one over n
which is changing the in the next uh
step
so this is what the
quantum unitary u uw does it flips the
amplitude and marks and thus marks the
state that we're looking for
uh
geometrically this corresponds to
rotation around the s prime uh
and we end up in a in a state that is
uh merely reflected
in
with respect to s prime
so the initial angle uh of s and s prime
was that theta
now it becomes uh theta again but from
the other side
and then the final step is to is to
rotate this once again
uh
that reflected with respect to s
uh in order to uh in order to get closer
to the state that we're looking for
amplitude wise it looks like this
so the amplitude of the state that we're
looking for is increased and thus the
probability of measuring this state goes
goes higher
um
i guess that's it for amplitude
amplification for now
uh
we with us uh achieve uh uh a larger
angle with the with the state that we
don't want and the smaller angle with
the state that we want why do we do all
of this why do we do reflections and
such uh instead of just rotating the
vector is uh because quantum quantum
unitaries have specifics that won't
allow us to simply rotate a vector in
the in this space
and uh we have to come up with creative
ways of reflecting uh back back and
forth in order to to go towards that
towards our goal w
uh
here we have an example of the of
grover's quantum circuit we we start
start with an empty zero state we create
a quantum superposition of state using
the the harmar gate as i've mentioned
before
we then
apply a grover iteration which consists
the unity you have
discussed before the one that marks our
state
it's also called oracle and uh the next
step is the diffuser which uh takes the
mark state and and rotates it once again
uh in the very end we measure uh hoping
that we'll end up we'll find the state
that we're looking for
however this is still not guaranteed
because of the probabilistic nature of
quantum computations
and uh
we we might still end up doing all of
our calculations again
uh however this works with a very high
probability
and practically it's been implemented
and shown that this indeed repeating
this procedure or square root of an of
times
uh more specifically pi over 4 times
square root of n it can this this uh
that number can be achieved by
geometrical proof which i won't perform
here
uh
by uh repeating this process procedure
uh this many times
we uh we we were guaranteed to end up
with a quantum state that we're looking
for
so how can we apply all of this to
machine learning
i will i will present two two examples
of applications quantum perception
models and quantum reinforcement
learning i won't dive very very deep
into into the theory behind i'll just
outline the the general algorithms and
uh and try to show where grover's search
fits in those and why why these are
better than the classical alternatives
so we'll start with quantum perception
models first a small reminder on
on perceptions different differences
between feature and version spaces
so here we we have a comparison of the
feature and the version space in the
feature space
we have our data points marked as dots
on the uh
the their dots and or crosses depending
on their label
uh and we have our classifiers
separating them uh in the
two-dimensional case those would be
uh lines uh however the an alternative
persian space representation to to to
this thing would be
uh
uh would be three-dimensional where data
points are planes
uh and for higher dimensions those would
be hyper planes and the classifiers that
we're looking for the separation lines
are actually dots on a
big yellow ball of all possible
classifiers normalized classifiers
and what we're trying to achieve here is
uh we restrict the space
uh the diversion space with data points
we divide it with planes
and we try to find
uh
find a corresponding point on the
on the
um
on the bow of or of all possible
classifiers that that will optimally
divide divide those between each other
so here we have an example of
of online quantum perception training
this is not very online because in
online training we usually
supply our data points to the
uh to the model in a stream stream like
fashion one by one however here here we
sample
sample them from the
uh set of all possible training points
in order to uh be able to achieve uh
quantum parallelism so so we'll need to
apply several operations on several
points
um
in order to to be able to gain the
quantum advantage that we want
very shortly we will
i will discuss this very shortly the the
most important step
here is the quantum
is the grover search or amplitude
amplification we pretty much create
a superposition over all possible
uh
all possible uh classifiers that we that
we're looking for
after which
we amplify the amplitude
through this step we amplify the
amplitude of the
of this uh of the state that we want
uh and we in the end we measure
hoping that we found a misclassified
state so in our case a state that we
want to find
is a quantumly encoded
feature vector along with this label
that is misclassified
after after finding a state like this we
just have to update the
the weights the corresponding weights
using the perception model
which i won't go very deep into today
uh we just have the standard rule of
updating uh of updating perceptron
weights
uh but the the the key point in this as
i've already mentioned is finding a
misclassified state and uh the reason
why this outperforms a classical
alternative is that
we will use quadratically less queries
to our database uh we will thus find a
misclassified state in a in a
in a quadratic last time
there's an alternative in the version
space which pretty much looks
very similar uh to the to the uh to the
feature space version
and
with the only difference that as we as
we can see here we have
a lot of possibilities for for the
classifiers
and uh we will try to uh in this
second algorithm we will try to randomly
uh sample
a possible uh hyper hyper
classifiers from from from the from this
ball
using a gaussian
spherical distribution
and uh search use the grover's quantum
search
uh to find an optimal classifier
the rest of the procedure is the same we
sample
we sample our
hyperplanes classifiers they're marked
as w's vectors w is here and we perform
a quantum search
uh here g stands for the oracle gate
that we've seen before and this
looks pretty much like the standard
diffuser gate thus this g-gate is uh
tasked with marking
with marking a potential
a potential classifier and
this second step is tasked with uh with
amplifying the probability of the
of measuring the optimal classifier
now i'd like to talk a bit about quantum
reinforcement learning
uh with and i'll start with a small
reminder of what reinforcement learning
is
uh if you if you're familiar with it
you're probably familiar with this
picture too
uh it is uh it corresponds to
uh to the two model of an environment
well you know where intelligent agents
take certain actions
that modify the environment and uh
feed feed the the resulting states after
those actions back into the agent
and uh
also they
gain some insight into how effective
their
action was
using using the reward system
and this this process is repeated
iteratively until we achieve our goal
which which can be different
from case case to case
[Music]
but uh
in
in in this model it's uh very practical
to use markov decision processes uh to
to model the environment thus will have
a certain action space a certain state
space
a
reward function which will
calculate the reward of certain actions
that the agent takes
and a corresponding value function which
is more like a long-term reward
and our goal in
reinforcement learning would be to to
optimize this value function in order to
gain maximum cumulative reward in a long
run
uh here we have another example of uh
of uh of an algorithm which we call
quantum reinforcement learning
uh
we have again the the main principle is
to create a quantum superposition over
all possible states
uh
which which will allow us to operate on
them
uh very very uh at the same time
parallelly pretty much
and what we would want here is to encode
our state's state and action space in a
quantum vector
uh in a quantum state
uh in order to uh to be able to apply
grover's search
so we
encode our state as a quantum vector we
create a uniform superposition over all
possible states of our system we create
universal superposition over all
possible actions
and we initialize our value function
which we're trying to maximize
arbitrarily
for all states in the in the
superposition
we repeat the procedure
of measuring an action thus
getting getting a certain action from
the superposition of all possible
actions uh after after which we take
this action
and we measure or we observe the the
state uh
that that results uh the resulting state
after this action and we also read the
corresponding reward
using the reward function
after which we used
a classical approach to updating our
value function
from reinforcement learning
we update uh
we update our probability amplitudes in
a way so that we we can differentiate
between the bad and the good actions in
this superposition
and uh and
and this step involves using again
grover search so
amplitude amplification that we can
we've covered before
and we repeat this process uh which is
halted when the change in our value
function
is not very significant anymore when we
we don't optimize that that much
uh an important uh characteristic of
this algorithm is that it
operates on all of the actions
simultaneously
thus by taking a certain action and
getting getting a certain reward
uh we can update all of the actions
because they're in the superposition of
all uh they're in a superposition with
each other so uh we we update all of the
actions all uh the set of all possible
actions that we can take
and we take note of that for for the
future future iterations of our
algorithm
um
here we have a familiar picture of
rotating uh
rotations in the
uh in the
in the vector representation of our of
our states and actions
uh we we're just trying to trying to
find an optimal action and reduce the
the probabilities of uh actions that are
not not so good for a use case
and the corresponding amplitude picture
is shown here so so we're trying to
maximize the amplitudes of good actions
that will uh result uh in in optimal
solution and we're trying to minimize
the
amplitudes of of the bad ones
here we have a standard crit world setup
for quantum reinforcement
for reinforcement learning in general
our goal in this case would be to go
from the starting point to the to the
goal point
uh g uh
by uh finding the the
shortest possible path
and uh as can be
as can be seen in uh in this graph uh
our quantum reinforcement learning
approach
outperforms the classical temporal
difference approach which is uh
which is a classical approach to
reinforcement learning by uh order of
several times in this case
uh so here we can see dependence of
steps
steps per each episode and the
depending on the actual episode
episodes are are just one iteration of
our algorithm so if we find one path
that's one episode if we find another
that's another episode and what we're
trying to achieve here is uh to find the
shortest path so it's going to take
several iterations several thousands
iterations as we can see in this case to
achieve this and
by using the quantum reinforcement
learning approach we can notice that we
managed to converge around
3000 episodes in
while with the with the classical
approach we have
about eight even a bit more
um
yeah on the on the left as i said is the
classical
uh is the classical version in the
middle is a simulated version on a
classical computer
and on the right is the
uh is the actual theoretical prediction
of how quantum computer would perform it
which and those two are not very
different among each other
there's another problem with the
classical approach is that
with for high learning grades
it might not converge for example a
learning rate of 0.01
we converge a learning rate of 0.02
we don't anymore and for higher rates
it's like that while with a quantum
approach
because of the specifics of of our
quantum surge algorithm we we managed to
converge uh
even for higher
rates up to
alpha
the learning grade rate equal to
point
point eleven
but the most importantly applications of
quantum
computing in machine learning are not
only one directional so the synergy
between the fields
works works in both ways we can thus for
example utilize
approaches of machine learning uh to to
optimize certain algorithms uh in uh in
quantum computing and grover's algorithm
is a good example of that
for
for example i didn't mention that in
order to be able to uh
uh to check if the solution if the state
that we found using grover search is
indeed a solution we have to
have an analytical way of verifying that
state
but sometimes that that may not be the
case depending on the
uh
depending on the specific problem and uh
some
machine learning techniques more
specifically neural networks
can be used to overcome this problem
however i won't cover that today
and very shortly i'd like to discuss
quantum supremacy
which is a
goal of proving that
quantum computers actually can perform
things
that
classical
computers can not infeasible amount of
time
and and as i've already mentioned in the
beginning it's been done very recently
by chinese scientists they
experimentally managed to on a very very
complex computer they managed to
achieve uh
computation in four hours which would
classically take several thousands of
years
uh among the advantages uh it should be
clear already that
uh we regain a speed up over the
classical alternatives in quantum and
quantum search and grow research that's
a quadratic speed up in other cases it
might be maybe even more significant or
even quadratic speed up for large
databases can be uh can be can be very
significant
we can solve quantum uh using quantum
computing we can solve uh certain
classically infeasible problems i've
already mentioned
the chinese researchers case
and uh also another
interesting application is the
simulation of quantum environments on
quantum computers which are classically
very hard and consuming to do
so
for example in physical applications in
chemistry applications we can simulate
quantum settings using quantum computers
the challenges associated with it
are
quantum decoherence
a
thing that pretty much breaks the
superposition if we interact with our
system too often or too much
and as i've already mentioned the
superposition is the thing that we want
to keep because it allows for quantum
parallelism and more efficient
computations
uh coupled with
the difficulty of building quantum
computers the technological
imperfections we arrive at a very high
error accumulation over computation
process
uh
and the the this is one of the research
fields of quantum computing we're trying
to reduce the errors as much as possible
and they're not very efficient for every
every type of computation so there are
specific applications of quantum
computing that
where we want we would want to use them
but mostly classical computers can solve
several problems far more efficiently
than the
the quantum computers
and finally the vanishing gradient is an
animal specific problem uh which which i
didn't cover uh today quantum neural
networks it's a concept
where we use utilize again quantum
computations in neural networks
and uh
we're all very familiar with the
vanishing gradient problem vanishing
gradient uh
in and in classical approach we just
utilize activation function to overcome
this however in quantum setting
because of the architecture specifics
it's not it's not possible
uh so to conclude i'll i just like to
say that uh if you if you haven't
started starting quantum computing you
definitely should because uh especially
if
you if you're into the data science
field
it has a lot of applications and whereas
it's not
very very popular today because of the
physical imperfections in the production
of quantum computers it will certainly
be
hopefully in the in the nearest future
uh i i'm optimistic not everyone in the
field is but uh
uh i strongly believe that this uh
quantum computing uh is is the future
are my references
that's it if there are any questions
thank you go ahead
yeah i have a question uh regarding the
progress algorithms i'm curious that
is it not possible to
arbitrarily manipulate the probabilities
of all the
items and the data research
so we're searching so what i mean is
that uh like in what we have shown we've
just like kind of doubled the
probability of the right item but is it
possible to like make it even higher
uh make it even higher yeah you mean two
to go even higher in this yeah so
ideally we would like
this item to have like four builder like
one close to one and we can
that's exactly why uh
a session we repeat this as many times
as needed to go even higher so so so we
would we would flip this again and again
and again and it will go higher
it is not exactly doubling it's getting
higher
uh while other amplitudes are getting
lower because they still their squares
still need to sum up to one
from the normalization principle but
essentially uh repeating this square
root of n times where n is the number of
the items we're searching we are very
very likely to to come very close to
this vector and measure the state that
we're looking at i was just curious that
like if we can double it every time
probably we can like get to
close to one in like over again
but
yes since i i got you that you're saying
it's it's not doubling it it may look
like it's stubborn condition it won't be
possible yeah i said thank you
you're welcome
so am i correct to say that like in
classical machine learning we are
optimizing our model right length we are
not starting from the states of
superpositions like here yes but here we
should start with like
this whole like space of our problem
right
so it's not we cannot stream the
problem in any way like we should start
with the whole space we start with the
whole space we uh for example in this
case we sample from the set of all
possible solutions
uh
from from the set of all possible
solutions we sample from this and then
we search among them that's that's why
we so not every model can be translated
like this that's another thing right
exactly exactly that's why i said that
not not every problem is solved
efficiently quantumly we can certainly
do that
but
because quantum machines are quantum
computers are fully functional turing
machines we can do that but we wouldn't
want to do that in most of the cases the
upper limit of our space would be the
entangled qubits right so like if we
have like 60 computer that's the upper
limit of problems that we can solve
uh it's it's a bit more complicated than
that since i've mentioned like uh
if we managed to create superposition
overall cubes that that would make our
computational power very very efficient
but yes we are physically obviously
limited to a certain amount of qubits at
this point
and that's one of the challenges we're
trying to
increase the number of qubits as much as
possible in order to gain improved
efficiency